celebrating her fifth Academy Award
nomination this year for little children
Kate Winslet
[Music]
cut to the chase
we don't really know who first uttered
that phrase perhaps it was the director
or the producer or the studio mogul or
the studio Mobile's girlfriend or the
truck driver waiting to deliver the
print to the theater but we know to whom
it was said the film editor doesn't
actually mean the actual chase it means
the moment we've been waiting for and
that's what I shall cut to right now
here are the nominees for best film
editing
Stephen Marioni and Douglas Christ for
Babel Stephen rosenbloom for Blood
Diamond Alex Rodriguez and Alfonso
Cuaron for children of mirth
Thelma Schoonmaker for the departing
Clare Douglas Christopher rouse and
Richard Pearson for United 93 and the
Oscar goes to Thelma Schoonmaker for the
departed film espuma
were met Martin Scorsese at NYU film
school in credited with changing her
life when he made her an editor
[Music]
thank you thank you this is the third
film you've not you were given the Oscar
- for that was made by Martin Scorsese
and believe me I know I wouldn't be
standing here if it wasn't for him you
can understand you can understand what
it was like to be given a film directed
the way he directed this movie with the
wonderful script by Bill Monahan
they're fantastic panoply of actors who
were just so magnificent working with
Marty is quite something its tumultuous
passionate funny and it's like being in
the best film school in the world
I'm so grateful to you and to my two
pillars in the editing room Scott Brock
Joel Hirsch and Rob legato and Ron Ames
for putting their arms around us and
doing the visual effects and supporting
us throughout and to you the members of
Academy I feel very honoured thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]